you know when I was talking about global
warming hours so simplifying that that's
a big important task but obviously that
in a way relates to the hilarious
comments on and on the productivity I
think actually bringing the the under
service they are the underdogs into the
global economy and improving their
living standards is another very
important possible potential area for
growth of course you would need to
balance it against the global warming
because as the Chinese and the Indians
start using automobiles and and and and
use energy it has accelerated global
warming but certainly reducing the the
differences in living standards taking
bringing the the underdogs into in into
the global economy is a tremendous area
for growth
you